the latest Sensational Revelation by
Prince Harry goes to the heart of a
troubled relationship with his brother
William heir to the throne the pair seen
here after the death of the queen
in a copy of Harry's upcoming
autobiography spare obtained by
Britain's Guardian newspaper the second
in line describes a 2019 meeting with
his brother on the Kensington Palace
estate it descended he says into
acrimony and then physical violence the
brothers had met to discuss their
failing relationship after Harry's 2018
marriage to U.S actor Meghan Markle and
the intrusive often insulting media
coverage that followed Harry writes that
William called Megan difficult rude and
abrasive after which things got heated
Harry writes that William grabbed me by
the collar ripped my necklace and
knocked me to the floor
it is the latest allegation to cast a
Paul over the house of Windsor
headquartered here at Buckingham Palace
there's been no response Royal insiders
say the palace has adopted a no comment
policy in the media build up to the
publication of Harry's book next week
not so members of the public I think
Brothers have scuffles all the time so
you know I think there's probably some
truth in it but I don't think it's as
bad as he's made out surely you you
sorted out within the family but you
want the whole world to know your dirty
laundry really for millions and millions
family tensions were most recently aired
in a Netflix documentary that Amplified
previous claims of racism made against
the Royal household which the palace at
the time denied it went further claiming
Megan suffered a miscarriage because of
stress caused by negative media coverage
and considered taking her own life and
there'll be more in lengthy U.S and UK
interviews to be broadcast on Sunday I
don't know how how staying silent is
ever going to make things better
wouldn't your brother say to you Harry
how could you do this to me after
everything after everything we went
through wouldn't that be what he would
say he'd probably say all sorts of
different things what the public makes
of it all is the real test of whether
these new stains on Royal Family
relations are Shrugged off or cause
further damage to the Royal brand Jonah
Al Jazeera London